I imagine I know it's it's not a biopic
of Gerhard Richter but you had to have a
conveyance you needed an artist to build
the story around and tell it so all the
artists you could have chosen why
Richter you know him it was really I
mean it started with the idea hadn't
known Richter all that well and I knew
there was this one very beautiful
painting that he'd done which was an
originally released as mother and child
and it shows beautiful young woman
holding a little baby and and then later
they explained that this was not
actually his mother and his child it was
and and her child it was him as a little
child being held by his mother's
youngest sister who shortly after that
photograph had developed schizophrenia
and had been murdered by the Nazis in
their eugenics program and and I always
found that you know it's most very you
know very moving and a very moving story
that he would build this memorial to his
aunt in this painting so many years
later and and it also gave a face to
these victims you know it's and and I
thought that I so that had always
interested me and then a journalist who
a very famous journalist in Germany he
did an interview with me I don't even
remember what it was about because I
soon noticed I was more interested in
interviewing him he was a really
interesting character and so I said you
know what else are you working on very
often journalists have another life
beyond their journalism they'd have a
kind of secret
Batman activity of and writing books or
plays or something and this man said
well actually you know I just took a
year off from the paper to write a
biography of galleys and I said it's
interesting why would you do that so
much has been written on him and he said
you know I I i did a background piece on
the leash tub and found out that that
the
the father of the woman that Lisa ended
up marrying or was actually a
high-ranking SS doctor and and a central
part of the eugenics program himself
responsible for nine hundred of the
forced sterilizations and someone who
got free and actually died in I think
1988 at age 94 or something it was it's
really and you know never got caught and
and then you know but if you look at
galleries does work it almost seems like
although no one could have known this
because he really kept managed to keep
it secret it's all there and I thought
wow that's is this is really interesting
you know this is a really interesting
starting point for for an exploration of
creativity and an artistic work and for
exactly what you described are kind of
how we can use how we can use all the
all the things that happen to us in life
to create something to create something
great and overcome it you know I mean I
think with every with every challenge
that we have in life you know with or
with every terrible thing that happens
to us we can always decide to you know
lie down and and die here or we can
decide to somehow try and overcome it
one of my great teachers and overcoming
the things is here today hey Arnold so
that's you know it is really I think
that's why art is something so wonderful
to us it is because it is living proof
and testament that we can overcome
things I think I really think that is
what gives us comfort in art why do we
like looking at a picture of you know
the the bombers throwing the bombs over
Dresden it's because we know this artist
experienced that and somehow overcome
overcame his trauma by putting it into
art and I think it's like that I mean
why do we enjoy listening to a why do we
enjoy listening to a song on the radio
about you know lost love and all that
it's because we know that somehow the
fact that this very song was written is
testament to the fact that it's possible
to get through it you know and and and
that is that's something that I wanted
to capture in in this film when you have
a director and a director of photography
I feel
there's always this magical alchemy that
happens that as a civilian is is magical
and is a little mysterious you know
you're the author of the story but
you're the visual author of the story
and it's like if you don't have the
right partner you might as well just
throw those pages out the window so
completely I mean that's completely true
and I've never experienced that more
just before you know we passed on to
Caleb I need to say that you know Caleb
has been really the director of
photography who brought me to understand
you know photography as art because it
was one of my very first times at the
movie theaters was we were living in New
York at the time and when I was seven
years old he brought me to the theater
to see there was an open-air theatre in
New York to see the Black Stallion and
this was Caleb's first feature as a
photographer and I mean it's basically
the film is all photography there's
hardly any dialogue because it's a boy
and a horse and and and so it is really
it is truly a film told in images and I
remember thinking you know understanding
that images can be art at that young age
and since then you know that there are
very few photographers for whom I will
actually just no matter what the movie
is I'll go and see it and and it was
like that with Caleb so I knew right
when I had the idea for this you know I
knew there were two people they
absolutely had on had to have on board
one was the actor who plays who plays
Sieben the evil dr. Sebastian Cole he
was you know him and that wonderful
meeting all those years ago and really
had he and I knew that I needed his
charm too in a way for this part because
otherwise this person is so evil and so
terrible that you know I'd be running
out of the theatre and the other person
I knew you know I needed was Caleb
Deschanel and I knew that he passes on
everything I know that from a lot of
directors and so I called him and said
Caleb can we meet for our coffee I just
need to tell you about this story and I
somewhat feel like I can't go into
writing it if you could you know if you
couldn't say that at least you'd be
interested in I
I'd better take over here so Florian
calls me he says I have this idea for a
movie and I really want to tell you
about it and so we meet at farm shop in
Santa Monica and at 9 o'clock in the
morning and we sat there and he's
telling me this story and I'm on the
edge of my seat the whole time which is
the story you see here on the screen and
we didn't leave til one o'clock
that's anyway they're drinking coffee
and I had like I think a bowl of oatmeal
or something and the whole rest of the
time I'm just listening to him telling
this incredible story that you know is
based on you know information that he
got from Richter and and I assumed some
of what he made up mm-hm and anyway it
took four hours so the film is actually
an hour short the story though that was
the first director's cut but I have to
say you know what I saw the movie you
know there are a couple of scenes
missing and even though it's so long
there you know there's scenes that I
really would have loved to have had left
in the movie I mean I wish that we could
have the actress here because the
actress were so incredible I mean to me
like one of the keys to the movie was
you know obviously all these incredibly
dramatic situations that he goes through
and then you know if you don't have him
had this epiphany and discover the you
know how to paint and you know you look
at that scene and it's you know where
he's he's finally discovering who he is
and it's a really complex scene and
really terrified me before we did it
because I did want to ask you about that
because that was all on you I mean you
say that but I think if you went back
and you looked at the movie and you
looked at you know Tom Schilling who
plays Kurt you see how much incredible
silent acting is in him where he makes
this discovery and you read it in his
eyes and in his behavior he really was a
good painter by the time yeah we did
those scenes and he really knew what he
was doing because he worked with some
really great painters who were as a
matter of fact one of the painters that
we worked with was actually Richter's
system
I mean the other thing is is sort of the
serendipity because it was always
written that the wind would blow and the
lights you know would turn off and then
you would see the you know the image on
the screen but there's a moment when you
introduce Kurt as an adult for the first
time Tom Schilling and he's up in a tree
and we had to you know we found this one
tree out the middle of nowhere in in
eastern Germany right by the the Polish
Czech border and you know we knew that
we needed a technic rate so we had a
technic rain out there and then on that
day we had the most incredible wind and
it was all mine it was just perfect
because it's a moment where he sort of
makes this revelation he comes and tells
his parents and his parents all think
he's going nuts yeah they're very happy
and you know because he has this
epiphany and and it just fed in
perfectly to the scene help me thank
Caleb and Gloria